german chancellor angela merkel has held
talks with ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky in kiev the two discussed an
end to the conflict with russian-backed
separatists in eastern ukraine
germany is a key ally of ukraine's but
there are also tensions over the north
stream two gas pipeline
kiev is strongly opposed to the route
which will ship gas directly from russia
to germany depriving ukraine of both
transit fees and geopolitical leverage
and potentially allowing russia to cut
off ukraine's gas while keeping western
europe supplied
16 years dozens of bilateral visits and
four ukrainian presidents
angela merkel is certainly no stranger
to this part of the world
she came to office just after the first
maidan revolution swept a new president
to power but ukraine only really came to
dominate germany's diplomatic agenda in
2014
when pro-european protesters once again
took to kiev's maidan square and brought
another pro-russian government down
soon former president viktor yanukovych
fled to moscow and the eu and russia
were on a collision course
within weeks russia annexed ukraine's
crimean peninsula and began supporting
pro-russian separatists in the donbass
region
full-scale open warfare in europe was a
reality for the first time since the
balkan wars of the 1990s thousands lost
their lives and hundreds of thousands of
people were forced to flee their homes
negotiations late into the night and
countless calls between kiev moscow
brussels and washington angela merkel
was at the forefront of the shuttle
diplomacy that prevented a local
conflict from escalating
she was also determined to make russia
pay for flouting international law in
ukraine
most analysts are certain without
merkel's lobbying eu sanctions against
russia would never have been passed
but seeing from kiev this was also a
time of mixed messages from germany
just months after the last tank battle
in donbass in june 2015 nordstrom 2 was
announced
a further gas pipeline linking russia
and germany through the baltic sea would
allow the kremlin to completely bypass
ukraine's pipelines
not only would ukraine lose billions in
annual transit fees but also a key
deterrent to further russian military
intervention in ukraine ukraine's
leaders hoped that u.s pressure would
stop the project but when president joe
biden withdrew sanctions after a meeting
with merkel in july 2021 it was clear
that the battle was lost
a dream that ukraine's leaders haven't
given up on is nato membership or
something close to it
but angela merkel was never the leader
they could look to for support
she repeatedly vetoed nato plans to give
kiev any overt security guarantees let
alone membership
fear of antagonizing russia
as angela merkel makes her final visit
to ukraine the conflict in donbass is
still no closer to a negotiated
resolution
the german chancellor will be remembered
in kiev as a leader who made stabilizing
ukraine a priority but who also often
disappointed her ukrainian counterparts
by her refusal to push back harder
against russia
for more let's bring in dw's nick
connolly who is standing by in kiev
hello to you nick
so you were following the press
conference what did the two leaders say
well this was essentially about two
things this was about security and
ukraine's ongoing tensions with russia
security in donbass and about energy
that nordstrom 2 pipeline through the
baltic sea you mentioned and from
ukrainian perspective those two things
are intrinsically linked ukrainians
saying that if germany commissions this
pipeline then russia basically will have
a free hand to up the pressure on
ukraine to destabilize this country
because up until now they have been
dependent on security here in ukraine to
supply their customers and earn those
crucial billions from european customers
from angela merkel we heard a kind of
personal note of disappointment that
those negotiations year after year on
donbass through the mints format that
they hadn't achieved more you have to
say that russia has handed out about
half a million passports in that region
to people living there and is now
encouraging people living there with
russian passports to take part in
russian elections so no real sign that
those are going to come under ukrainian
control anytime soon and from vladimir
zelinski there was more of his criticism
of this pipeline he called it a weapon
that germany was needlessly basically
handing over to the russians he was
skeptical that the compensatory
mechanisms would work that ukraine would
get much in return and basically said
that the sanctions that are meant to
happen if russia does weaponize energy
were unenforceable so
very difficult to uh you know see any
closer positions there
well it was just two days ago that
angela merkel had a surprisingly warm
welcome from vladimir putin when she was
in moscow
just how welcome is the german
chancellor in kiev
well there were obviously warm words
from the host from vladimir zelensky and
recognition that angela merkel has
invested a huge amount of political
capital in ukraine down the years
especially in those last seven years
since russia annex crimea and began
supporting those separatists in donbass
but there was no overlooking those
tensions and you know the atmospherics
weren't particularly relaxed
voldemosilenski coming back to that
energy topic time and time again um
germany has said it will invest in
renewables here in ukraine to try and uh
dampen the blow from ukraine losing that
gas transit um and you would
try and prevent russia from weaponizing
energy but there was also talk of
military aid the ukrainians would like
germany to support ukraine's military as
the us and the uk are doing uh maybe
help rebuild its uh black sea fleet but
germany's staying very very quiet about
that no real willingness to provide
ukraine with lethal weapons and there's
a real disappointment here in kiev among
people who maybe are
expecting more from germany that germany
to their mind isn't willing to get off
the fence and take sides for ukraine and
is trying to you know basically keep its
roles a mediator between russia and
ukraine that's something that is
frustrating people here in ukraine as
this conflict continues
dw's nate connolly reporting for us from
kiev thanks so much
you